If he were to obey you in much
your whims, you would result,
it would result in your
hardship. So, it is a blessing
from Allah. That's the prophet
does not respond to our whims
and does not give us what we
want. He gives us what we need.
He gives us what is appropriate
for us. Likewise is the
situation. With regards to what
we receive from Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. We ask Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala for certain
things. If you were to give us
everything that we asked for,
this would be negative. Because
honestly we don't know what's
good for us and what's bad for
us. We don't know what's good
for other people, what's bad
for other people. Honestly, we
don't know sometimes the the
the truth behind what we're
asking for, right? So, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says here
that it is a blessing from him
that the prophet does not obey
the majority of the whims of
those around him. Rather it is
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
made a man through faith,
beloved to the companions, and
those who are most him,
most them. and he
beautified and adorned this
faith in their hearts. And he
made it that their hearts
disliked and he made it hated
to their hearts, Disbelief and
major sin and all sin in
general. People who have who
are most described with those
descriptions. Those who love
what Allah loves, hate what
Allah hates, they love
faith, holistically, and
generally and it is beautiful
to them, and they hate
disbelief, and major sin, and
all sin, specifically, these
are people who are most guided,
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
he described them as being
individuals who are enlightened
Truly and enlightened. Not only
he described them as being
enlightened and guided but he
described them as being
enlightened, guided, and strong
upon that guidance. Allah then
tells us why it is that he
blessed and endowed those
people. That came before us and
those around the prophet with
what he endowed them. He said
this is out of grace from Allah
and blessing. It is purely from
Allah's grace and purely from
Allah's generosity. And Allah
is all knowing, all wise. He's
all knowing with regards to who
are most worthy of these
traits. And he is most wise.
How he distributes these traits
amongst his servants.
[Arabic recitation]